je vais vous montrer une innovation qui
est super intéressante qu'il y a combiné
de la réalité mixte on est sur le stand
de Qualcomm au MWC en fait il nous
montre innovation qui est super
intéressante alors là j'ai mes lunettes
de réalité mixte c'est-à-dire que je
vais avoir de la réalité augmentée il y
a un côté aussi un petit peu feutré qui
vient m'enfermer un peu sur la
pseudo-réalité virtuelle donc c'est
développé totalement sur la base de quoi
comme sur le slam dragons spaces alors
ce que ça vient faire ça vous donne une
solution plutôt pour les professionnels
pour l'industrie pour le B2B je vous dis
ce que je vois en fait et bien ça vient
scanner ce cube là bas et grâce à ce
cube je vais pouvoir voir des solutions
super intéressantes mes lunettes grâce
aux caméras et bien je vais pouvoir
venir reconstruire par exemple un modèle
de lave-vaisselle industriel avec une
vraie découpe voir au travers ce qu'il y
a par exemple vous voulez venir
convaincre un client pourquoi cette
solution est intéressante par rapport à
une autre vous allez avoir une visite
virtuelle en gros vous allez voir ce qui
passe à l'intérieur de ce lave-vaisselle
si on prend cet exemple là moi j'ai mes
lunettes mais également le collaborateur
à côté peut avoir ses lunettes et
visualiser exactement la même chose ça
se base aujourd'hui sur les technologies
de Qualcomm ici omwc ça super
intéressant il va plus comme technologie
et je suis vraiment content de vous
montrer les usages qu'on peut avoir pour
les professionnel